un soulagement mesuré c'est le sentiment
qui domine ce matin dans cette station
service la remise de 15 centimes par
litre sur tous les carburants a annoncé
hier par le gouvernement combine
certains automobilistes mais pas tous
un petit coup de pouce à l'ensemble des
français c'est autour d'un bon moi je
pense que toute baisse est bonne à
prendre 1 ou la pro b pour moi c'est une
bonne surprise pour moi 15 centimes en
fait ça me paraît un effort mais pas
forcément
le plus gros effort qu'il puisse faire
notre cas nous les taxes et c'est pas
suffisant si pacifique pour un plein de
68 cette aide sera donc de 9 euros tous
les français sont concernés particuliers
comme professionnels pêcheurs
agriculteurs artisans du btp routier
taxi cette baisse sera directement
appliquée à la pompe les distributeurs
se feront ensuite rembourser par l'état
la mesure entre en vigueur à partir du
1er avril pour quatre mois mais dès
demain certaines enseignes devraient
afficher des tarifs plus bas car le
cours du pétrole s'est déjà infléchi en
fin de semaine
c'est quasi instantanée les les
répercussions des variations du prix du
baril à la pompe se font pratiquement au
jour le jour en ce moment tellement ces
variations sont violentes donc les y est
les clients ont pu constater d
augmentation très significative de prix
à la pompe cette semaine qu'ils vont
peut-être disparaître si le prix du
baril se re stabilise aux alentours de
110 heures on reste quand même je
rappelle à des prix historiquement élevé
le coup de pouce du gouvernement coûtera
2 milliards d'euros il est déjà jugé
insuffisant par l'association de
consommateurs ufc que choisir qui
réclame une baisse de la tva